once the two panes are showing up on a
tablet let's modify our code to handle
the list item click on the phone if an
item is clicked in the forecastfragment
then we must launch the detail activity
on a tablet UI once an item in the
forecastfragment is clicked we notify
the main activity which goes and
replaces the detail fragment the reason
the two fragments don't talk to each
other is because we want to maintain
abstraction from each other if the
forecast list fragment started assuming
that the detail fragment was always
right next to it then the sumption would
break for example on the phone where the
detail fragment is not inside the main
activity therefore a fragment must go
through its activity and the activity
must know how to dispatch the event to
the other fragments keep in mind that a
fragment doesn't always have to be used
in the same activity in order for the
forecast fragment to talk to the main
activity we should create a callback
interface it's a better assumption to
say that the fragment will always be
within an activity that implements this
callback than to say that the forecast
fragment will always be inside the main
activity the detail fragment is a good
example of how a fragment can be used in
two different activities the main
activity and the detail activity so
don't rely on get activity returning a
specific activity class using the gist
that we provided use the callback class
to notify the activity that a list item
has been selected see the hint below on
the item click listener then the
activity can either launch the detail
activity or replace the detail fragment
based on whether it's a phone or tablet
when you work on this task you'll run
into an issue of how to pass the
selected items URI to the detail
fragment now your instinct might say to
create a custom constructor where you
can pass in the date however we don't
normally create custom fragment
constructors
if you ever rotate the device for
example the system can't call your
custom fragment constructor with the
right parameters however it can use the
empty fragment constructor and
initialize it with the same bundle of
arguments you used earlier so the pass
information to initialize a fragment
create a bundle of key value pairs and
then set that as the arguments on the
fragment don't confuse this arguments
bundle with the saved instance date
bundle once a fragment has been
initialized you can't change the
arguments you can only read from them as
seen here on the other hand the save
site bundle is restoring information
once a fragment has been running and
can populate it in the on safe instance
state method the bundle can preserve
state across orientation changes or if
the fragment or activity gets killed by
the system that's why you receive it
back again in the oncreate or
oncreateview methods once the detail
fragment starts being displayed on the
tablet we need to make sure that doesn't
get out of date if the location changes
if the user went to settings and entered
in a new location when they come back to
the main activity in the on resume
method we should detect that the
location has changed we do this by
comparing the EM location string with a
location that stored and shared
preferences if there's a difference then
we find the forecast fragment and notify
that the location has changed similarly
we find the detail fragment and notified
that the location has changed since the
detail fragment is a dynamically added
fragment we need to make sure we find
the right instance in the fragment
manager we do this by calling fine
fragment by tag and passing in this tag
we associated this tag with this
fragment when we first did the fragment
transaction to add it to the screen if
you didn't already create a tag and
associate it with the detail fragment in
the fragment transaction then go ahead
and do it now in the oncreate method of
the main activity and you'll notice that
the detail fragment tag is just declared
as the string at the top of the file
after we make the changes to the main
activity we go over to the detail
fragment we add a new method on location
changed that takes in a new location
string first we try to figure out what
is the date for the data that we're
currently showing then we create a new
URI with the new location as well as the
date that we're already displaying we
update the EM URI and then we restart
the loader see the instructor notes for
the code related to handling the
location change this is what the app
should look like when you're done when
you tap on a different date it updates
the detail pane you can remove any
hard-coded data because the layout
should be populated dynamically now